What's history good for anyway? A couple of years ago I went with a group of Chicago eighth-graders on their class trip to Washington DC. And their teacher, Mr. Perlstein had all these ambitious plans for the trip. And one of the most ambitious involved us going up to the top of the steps at the Lincoln Memorial. And we had brought with us this boom box, this massive boom box, like, 20 D cells in this thing, just for this moment at the top of the stairs. And Mr. Perlstein had to get special permits from the US Park police just for this one moment.
历史到底有什么用？几年前，我陪一群芝加哥八年级的学生去华盛顿特区参加班级旅行。他们的老师珀尔斯坦先生为这次旅行做了许多宏大的计划。其中最宏大的计划之一，就是让我们登上林肯纪念堂的台阶。为了在登上台阶的那一刻能用上，我们还特意带了一个巨大的便携式音箱，这玩意儿足足用了20节D型电池。珀尔斯坦先生为了这一刻，还得特意从美国公园警察局申请特别许可证。
The class was all African-American and Mexican-American kids from the west side of Chicago. And Mr. Perlstein had this idea that we would sit there on the stairs right near where the Reverend Dr. Martin Luther King gave the "I Have a Dream" speech in 1963.
这个班级的学生都是来自芝加哥西区的非裔和墨西哥裔孩子。珀尔斯坦先生有一个想法，就是让我们坐在台阶上，坐在马丁·路德·金牧师1963年发表“我有一个梦想”演讲的地方附近。
All right, listen up. Dr. King spoke from the marble stairway to the right, approximately where that gentleman's walking up with the red backpack. Look out into the distance, you can see, first, the reflection pool. Do you remember the picture I showed you of people standing in the trees? Those are the trees over there on the left. Remember, they were up in the trees with the signs?
好了，都听着。金博士是在右侧的大理石台阶上演讲的，大约就是那位背着红书包的先生走上来的地方。看向远方，首先可以看到倒影池。还记得我给你们看的那张照片吗？人们站在树上？那就是左边的那几棵树。记住，他们当时就站在树上举着标语。
Mr. Perlstein talked for a while, trying to evoke that day of 1963. A cassette of Dr. King was queued up in the boom box.
珀尔斯坦先生讲了一会儿，试图还原1963年的那天。音箱里已经准备好了金博士的演讲录音带。
Sit back. Transport yourself into the past.
坐好，把自己带回过去。
(SUBJECT) MARTIN LUTHER KING, JR. I have a dream that one day, down in Alabama, with its vicious racists, with its governor having his lips dripping with the words of interposition and nullification, one day right there in Alabama, little black boys and black girls will be able to join hands with little white boys and white girls as sisters and brothers. I have a dream today.
(主题) 马丁·路德·金。我有一个梦想，有一天，在阿拉巴马州，那里的种族主义者心怀恶意，州长嘴里滴着阻碍和废除法律的言辞，就在阿拉巴马州，黑人小男孩和黑人小女孩能够像兄弟姐妹一样，与白人小男孩和白人小女孩手拉手。我今天有一个梦想。
The class listens, staring out in the distance over the reflecting pool toward the Washington Monument. A few passing tourists stop and stand and listen with us. Dr. King's voice reverberates out over the stairs. And, afterwards, I ask the kids about it. And it turns out you don't get to be a 14 year old, minority kid in the public schools in America without having heard the, "I Have a Dream" speech a few times. Most of the kids were like, that speech? Again?
学生们听着，凝视着远方，越过倒影池看向华盛顿纪念碑。几个路过的游客停下脚步，和我们一起站着聆听。金博士的声音在台阶上回荡。事后，我问了孩子们对此的看法。结果发现，作为一个14岁的美国公立学校少数族裔孩子，你不可能没听过几次“我有一个梦想”的演讲。大多数孩子就像是在说，又是那个演讲？又来了？
It wasn't emotional or anything. We just had to sit there and listen to it, the same old speech. You know, I thought it was going be real moving or something like that, but it was just listening to him talk, you know?
那一点也不感人或者别的什么。我们只是坐在那里听，还是那段老掉牙的演讲。你知道，我原以为这会非常动人或者类似的，但就只是听他说话而已，你懂吗？
And you've heard that speech before?
你以前听过那段演讲吗？
Thousands of times. Thousands of times.
几千遍了。几千遍了。
To be fair to these kids, what exactly is somebody supposed to do on the tourist sites of our own history? How exactly is it supposed to touch us? On our national holidays we pack up our children and we drive to Gettysburg and Williamsburg, to the Alamo and to the grassy knoll near the Dallas book depository, to the house where Richard Nixon grew up and to Al Capone's cell in Alcatraz. And we stand there, thousands and thousands of us, maybe even right now people standing there staring at the historic sites, trying to imagine what it was like back then, trying to absorb something, some lesson, some feeling, into ourselves. It's not easy.
平心而论，面对这些孩子，人们在自己的历史旅游景点到底该做些什么呢？这些景点究竟应该怎样触动我们？在国定假日，我们带上孩子驱车前往葛底斯堡和威廉斯堡，前往阿拉莫和达拉斯图书仓库附近的草丘，前往理查德·尼克松长大的房子，前往阿尔卡特拉斯监狱里阿尔·卡彭的牢房。我们站在那里，成千上万的人，也许此时此刻就有人正站在那里盯着那些历史遗迹，试图想象当年的情景，试图将某种东西、某种教训、某种感觉吸收到自己身上。这并不容易。
Santayana said, "Those who cannot remember the past are condemned to repeat it." But, you know, the opposite is also true. Those who can remember the past are also condemned to repeat it to their children on summer road trips. But, besides repeating it to someone else, what are you supposed to do with history? Especially history as ambiguous as that of our beloved United States of America, a history that's alternately murderous and heroic, money grubbing and idealistic.
桑塔亚纳说过：“不能记住过去的人，注定要重蹈覆辙。”但是，你知道，反过来也一样。那些能记住过去的人，也注定要在暑期自驾游时向他们的孩子重复这些历史。但是，除了向别人重复之外，你还能拿历史怎么办呢？尤其是像我们亲爱的美利坚合众国这样模糊的历史，一段时而残酷时而英勇、时而贪财时而理想主义的历史。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today, on our program, we try to make some sense out of the past. Writer Sarah Vowell and her twin sister, Amy, head out on the road to visit the site of a historic tragedy, one that involved part of their own family 160 years ago. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，我们在节目中尝试从过去中理出一些头绪。作家莎拉·沃威尔和她的双胞胎妹妹艾米踏上旅程，去探访一个历史悲剧的现场，那段悲剧在160年前涉及她们自己的家庭。请继续收听。
Sarah and Amy were born in Oklahoma, where our story ends and where it also begins. They're part Cherokee. That's an important element to their story. We're going to be devoting our entire program today to their trek through history. It's a story of the past and what to make of the past today.
莎拉和艾米出生在俄克拉荷马州，那既是我们故事结束的地方，也是它开始的地方。她们有部分切罗基血统。这是她们故事中的一个重要元素。今天我们将把整个节目专门用于她们的历史之旅。这是一个关于过去，以及今天如何看待过去的故事。
Being at least a little Cherokee in northeastern Oklahoma is about as rare and remarkable as being a Michael Jordan fan in Chicago. I mean, who isn't? I'm 1/8 Cherokee on my mother's side, about 1/16 on my father's. It goes without saying that my twin sister, Amy, is too, except that I have dark eyes and dark hair and she's a blue-eyed blond. And so our grandfather nicknamed me "Injun" and her "Swede."
在俄克拉荷马州东北部，拥有至少一点切罗基血统就像在芝加哥成为迈克尔·乔丹的粉丝一样稀松平常。我的意思是，谁不是呢？我母亲那边有八分之一切罗基血统，父亲那边大约十六分之一。不用说，我双胞胎妹妹艾米也是，只不过我有深色的眼睛和深色的头发，而她是蓝眼睛的金发女郎。所以我们祖父给我起了个绰号叫“印第安人”，给艾米起了个绰号叫“瑞典人”。
Here's Amy's take on all this. I must point out that, while my sister and I don't really look alike, we sound almost exactly alike. A hint for listening to this story, I'm usually the grouchy one. Here's Amy.
这是艾米对此的看法。我必须指出，虽然我和妹妹看起来不太像，但我们的声音几乎一模一样。听这个故事的小贴士：我通常是那个脾气暴躁的。下面是艾米。
I mean, those roles were assigned to us-- you know, Indian and Swede-- because of the way we looked, but it was also more like the things we were told about ourselves. And she was the one who was given the Cherokee language book, and I was the one who was always told how much alike I was to our Swedish grandmother. And I think I was probably six, or seven, or something before I realized that I was Cherokee too.
我的意思是，那些角色是我们被赋予的——你知道，印第安人和瑞典人——是因为我们的外貌，但也更多是因为我们被告知关于自己的事情。她是那个拿到切罗基语书的人，而我是那个总是被告知我和我们的瑞典祖母有多像的人。我想我大概六七岁左右才意识到我自己也是切罗基人。
We're a little French and Scottish and English and Seminole too, typical American mutts, but the Cherokee and Swedish sides of the family were the only genealogies anyone knew anything about. Here's what we knew about ourselves, Ellis Island, Trail of Tears. And I think, to a kid, "trail of tears," the Cherokee's forced march from the East to Oklahoma where we were born, seemed enormously more interesting, just as a name.
我们还有一点法国、苏格兰、英国和塞米诺尔血统，典型的美国杂种，但切罗基和瑞典血统是家族中唯一为人所知的家谱。我们对自己了解的情况是：埃利斯岛、眼泪之路。我认为，对一个孩子来说，“眼泪之路”——切罗基人从东部被强迫迁徙到我们出生的俄克拉荷马州的那段路——作为一个名字，看起来要有趣得多。
Even the smallest children know what tears mean, and I think in my earliest understanding of where I came from, I pictured myself descended from a long line of weepers with bloodshot eyes. The Trail of Tears, between 1838 and '39 the US Army wrenched 16,000 people from their homes, rounded them up in stockades, and marched them across the country. 4,000 died.
即使是最小的孩子也知道眼泪意味着什么。我想，在我最早对自己出身的理解中，我把自己想象成一群眼睛充血的哭泣者的后代。眼泪之路，在1838年到1839年间，美国陆军将16000人从家中强行驱逐，把他们关进栅栏里，然后驱赶他们横穿整个国家。4000人因此丧生。
Every summer when we were children, our parents would drive us to a place about half an hour from where we lived called Tsa-La-Gi, which is the Cherokee word for Cherokee. Tsa-La-Gi is the tribe's cultural center. There's a re-created colonial village, a museum, and-- this was our favorite part-- an amphitheater which staged a dramatic re-creation of the Trail of Tears. Every summer we watched Chief John Ross try like mad to save the Cherokee land back east. We saw his hot-head rival, Stand Watie, rage off to the civil war. We especially loved the Death of the Phoenix, a noisy, magenta-lit interpretive dance in which the mythic bird would die only to rise again.
我们小时候的每个夏天，父母都会开车带我们去一个离我们住处大约半小时车程的地方，叫Tsa-La-Gi，这是切罗基语中“切罗基人”的意思。Tsa-La-Gi是部落的文化中心。那里有一个重建的殖民村庄、一个博物馆，还有——这是我们最喜欢的部分——一个露天剧场，上演着眼泪之路的戏剧重现。每个夏天，我们都看着约翰·罗斯酋长拼命试图保住切罗基人在东部的土地。我们看到他那个脾气火爆的竞争对手斯坦·瓦蒂愤怒地投身于内战。我们特别喜欢“凤凰之死”，那是一场喧闹、在洋红色灯光照射下的解读舞蹈，神话中的鸟在死去之后又重生。
We would get these programs, or brochures, and Sarah was kind of in charge of them. And sometimes she'd let me look at them. She had a whole little file, and we would look through them. And I did take it to heart. It was a story that was really tragic. I have a sort of reverent feeling towards it, and I think it's because of this play. Because this play was so serious and told such a detailed story, that it kind of took this place of significance, like it was really important and it really mattered.
我们会拿到这些节目单或小册子，莎拉通常负责保管它们。有时她会让我看。她有一个完整的小档案袋，我们会翻看它们。我确实记在心里了。这是一个非常悲惨的故事。我有一种崇敬的感觉，我想这都是因为这部剧。因为这部剧太严肃了，讲的故事又那么细致，它占据了一个非常重要的位置，就像它真的很重要，真的很关键一样。
Here's the measure of how important the amphitheater show was to Amy and me. Our father and our grandfather used to show us photographs of Cherokee leaders in books, but, even now, when I imagine Stand Watie, I picture the actor at Tsa-La-Gi. So all my life I knew I wouldn't exist but for the Trail of Tears, and it struck me as a little silly that most of the things I knew about it were based on an amphitheater drama I haven't seen for nearly 20 years.
这是露天剧场的表演对艾米和我有多重要的衡量标准。我们的父亲和祖父常在书里给我们看切罗基领袖的照片，但即使是现在，当我想象斯坦·瓦蒂时，我脑海里出现的还是Tsa-La-Gi里的那位演员。所以我这一生都知道，如果不是因为眼泪之路，我就不会存在。而且我觉得有点可笑，关于这件事的大部分知识都来自于一部我已经近20年没看过的露天剧场话剧。
At first, I thought I'd read some books about it, which I did. But then I wanted to see it, feel it, know how long a trek it was. I wanted it to be real. I enlisted Amy. Perhaps she'd like to do all the driving? A historical tragedy and five 14-hour days behind the wheel? Who could pass that up? And so I fly from Chicago, she from Montana. And one spring morning we find ourselves in a rental car on our way to northwestern Georgia, the homeland of the Cherokee before they were shoved out to Oklahoma, the place the Trail of Tears begins.
起初，我想读几本相关的书，我也确实读了。但后来我想亲眼看看，亲身感受一下，知道这段路程到底有多远。我想让它变得真实。我拉上了艾米。也许她愿意开车？一场历史悲剧，加上五天每天14小时的驾驶？谁能错过这个？于是我从芝加哥飞过来，她从蒙大拿州飞过来。在一个春天的早晨，我们坐进了一辆租来的车，前往佐治亚州西北部——切罗基人在被驱逐到俄克拉荷马州之前的家园，眼泪之路开始的地方。
The Cherokee territory once encompassed most of present-day Tennessee and Kentucky as well as parts of Alabama, Georgia, Virginia, and the Carolinas. Even before contact with the Europeans in 1540, they were a proto-democratic society. They built these enormous council houses, big enough to fit the entire tribe inside, so everyone could participate in tribal decisions.
切罗基领地曾经囊括了现在田纳西州和肯塔基州的大部分地区，以及阿拉巴马州、佐治亚州、弗吉尼亚州和卡罗来纳州的部分地区。甚至在1540年与欧洲人接触之前，他们就是一个原始民主社会。他们建造了巨大的议会大厦，大到足以容纳整个部落，这样每个人都能参与部落决策。
We're barely on the road an hour when we spot them, Injuns. Ceramic ones, three feet tall, at a shack on the side of the road. Amy drives past them. We do a double take, and we don't even discuss whether or not to stop, she just backs up immediately and parks.
我们开车还没过一个小时就发现了它们：印第安人像。陶瓷做的，三英尺高，在路边的一个棚屋旁。艾米开车经过。我们又回头看了一眼，甚至没讨论要不要停下，她直接倒车停了下来。
Are you of Native American descent?
你是美洲原住民后裔吗？
I'm a Mexican. I'm from Texas.
我是墨西哥人。我来自德克萨斯州。
From Texas? And what brought you to Calhoun, Georgia?
来自德克萨斯州？是什么把你带到佐治亚州卡尔霍恩的？
The work.
工作。
The eight little Indians he's selling are of the kitschy, teepee-toting, Plains Indian, squaws and braves variety, which are probably a lot easier to sell than the stereotypical image of a Cherokee. A tired out old woman tromping through the Trail of Tears in rags, who wants that as a lawn ornament?
他卖的那八个小印第安人属于那种俗气的、背着帐篷、平原印第安人、印第安妇女和武士风格的雕像。这可能比切罗基人的刻板印象——一个疲惫不堪的老妇人穿着破烂衣服走在眼泪之路上——更容易卖出去。谁会把那个当作草坪装饰品呢？
Who buys these statues, these Indian statues?
谁会买这些雕像，这些印第安人雕像？
People here from Calhoun, around Georgia. People here around Georgia love Indians.
这里的人，卡尔霍恩的人，佐治亚州周围的人。佐治亚州这里的人喜欢印第安人。
Really?
真的吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
Well, after they got rid of them? [LAUGHS]
好吧，在他们把印第安人赶走之后？(笑)
That's right. [LAUGHS] That's true.
没错。(笑) 那是真的。
[LAUGHTER]
(笑声)
You're telling the truth there.
你说的确实是事实。
Thank you, very much.
非常感谢。
Uh-huh.
嗯。
The Cherokee, especially the mixed bloods, were always your nerdy, overachiever, bookish, sort of tribe. And, in the early 19th century, they launched a series of initiatives directly imitating the new American republic. In one decade, they created a written language, started a free press, ratified a constitution, and founded a capital city. New Echota was that capital. Now it stands in the middle of nowhere, a Georgia state park with a handful of buildings across from a golf course.
切罗基人，尤其是混血儿，一直都是那种书呆子气、好胜、爱读书的部落。19世纪初，他们发起了一系列直接模仿新成立的美国共和国的举措。十年间，他们创造了一种书面语言，创办了自由媒体，批准了一部宪法，并建立了一个首府城市。新埃克塔就是那个首都。现在它矗立在荒郊野外，是一个佐治亚州立公园，高尔夫球场对面只有几栋建筑。
Can we follow you in this car?
我们能开着车跟在你后面吗？
Drive on in.
开进去吧。
OK.
好的。
New Echota was founded in 1825. To call it the Cherokee version of Washington DC is entirely applicable, given the form of government the tribe established there. They ratified a constitution based on that of the United States, dividing into legislative, judicial, and executive branches. Its preamble begins, "We, the Representatives of the people of the Cherokee Nation in Convention assembled, in order to establish justice, ensure tranquility, promote our common welfare, and secure to ourselves and to our posterity the blessings of liberty."
新埃克塔建于1825年。鉴于该部落在那里建立的政府形式，称其为“切罗基版的华盛顿特区”完全适用。他们批准了一部基于美国宪法的宪法，划分为立法、司法和行政部门。它的序言开头写着：“我们，切罗基民族人民的代表在大会上聚集，为了建立正义，确保安宁，促进我们的共同福祉，并为我们自己及我们的后代确保自由的祝福。”
Unlike Washington, New Echota is cool and quiet and green. Site manager, David Gomez, showed us around the grounds. And Amy and I were unprepared for the loveliness of the place, for its calm lushness, its fragrance. Everywhere, honeysuckle was in bloom.
与华盛顿不同，新埃克塔凉爽、安静且绿意盎然。现场经理大卫·戈麦斯带着我们参观了场地。艾米和我对这个地方的可爱，以及它的平静、葱郁和芬芳毫无准备。到处都是盛开的金银花。
I like it here.
我喜欢这里。
It's nice. It's peaceful and it's right. The atmosphere is right for what was going on in the story that we tell here, you know? It's a story that's sad in a lot of ways, but there was a lot of great things happening with the Cherokee Nation.
这很好。这里很平静，而且感觉很对。这种氛围非常适合我们在这里讲述的故事，你知道吗？这是一个在很多方面都很悲伤的故事，但切罗基民族也发生过许多伟大的事情。
The Cherokee, along with the other Southeastern tribes who suffered removal to Oklahoma-- the Chickasaw, the Creek, the Chocktaw, the Seminole, are one of the, so-called, five civilized tribes.
切罗基人，连同其他遭受迁徙到俄克拉荷马州的东南部部落——奇卡索人、克里克人、乔克托人和塞米诺尔人——是所谓的“五大文明部落”之一。
It was in 1822 that the Cherokee hero, Sequoyah, developed an alphabet, inventing the sole written language of any North American tribe. Only six years later Cherokee editor, Elias Boudinot, founded The Cherokee Phoenix, a bilingual English-Cherokee newspaper published at New Echota.
1822年，切罗基英雄塞阔雅开发了一种字母表，发明了北美任何部落中唯一的书面语言。仅六年后的1828年，切罗基编辑伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特在新埃克塔创办了《切罗基凤凰报》，这是一份英、切双语报纸。
Many Cherokee, especially the mixed bloods, practice Christianity. And, because many of these lived as civilized Southern gentleman of the early 19th century, they owned prospering plantations, which meant they owned black slaves. More than any other Native American tribe, the Cherokees adopted the religious, cultural, and political ideals of the United States, partly as a means to self-preservation. By becoming more like the Americans, they hoped to co-exist with this new nation that was growing up around them. They weren't allowed to. Georgia settlers wanted their land and their gold, which was discovered near New Echota in 1829.
许多切罗基人，尤其是混血儿，信奉基督教。由于这些人中的许多人像19世纪初的文明南方绅士一样生活，他们拥有繁荣的种植园，这意味着他们拥有黑人奴隶。与其他美洲原住民部落相比，切罗基人更多地采纳了美国的宗教、文化和政治理想，部分是为了自我保护。通过变得更像美国人，他们希望与这个在他们周围兴起的新国家共存。但他们不被允许。佐治亚州的定居者想要他们的土地和黄金，黄金是1829年在新埃克塔附近发现的。
They were really progressing so fast at this time period. The printing operation was going with their newspaper here. Things were moving so fast forward and for a short while here that it looked very promising. But because of gold and the big demand for land, the fate had already been really sealed for them in earlier years.
当时他们真的进步得非常快。印刷业务和他们的报纸在这里运营着。事情发展得如此迅速，在很短的一段时间里，前景看起来非常光明。但由于黄金和大片土地的需求，他们的命运在早些年就已经注定了。
The tribe allowed Christian missionaries to live and work among them and to teach their children English. The most beloved of these was the Presbyterian, Samuel Worcester, who built a two-story house at New Echota which functioned as a post office, school and rooming house. It's still there, and David Gomez walks us through.
部落允许基督教传教士在他们中间生活和工作，并教他们的孩子英语。其中最受爱戴的是长老会传教士塞缪尔·伍斯特，他在新埃克塔盖了一栋两层楼的房子，兼作邮局、学校和招待所。房子还在那里，大卫·戈麦斯带我们参观了内部。
All right, we've got some steep steps here. You all hold on when you go down. I don't want you all to have a broken leg on the rest of your trip.
好了，这里的台阶很陡。你们下去的时候要扶好。我可不想你们在接下来的旅途中摔断腿。
The state of Georgia, which of all the Southern states treated the Cherokee with the most hostility, passed a number of alarming laws in the 1820s and '30s undermining the sovereignty of the nation. One of these laws required white settlers within the boundaries of the nation to obtain a permit from the state of Georgia. Samuel Worcester refused to apply for such a permit, arguing that he had the permission of the Cherokee to live on their lands and that should suffice.
佐治亚州在所有南方州中对切罗基人最不友好，它在19世纪20年代和30年代通过了一系列令人震惊的法律，破坏了该民族的主权。其中一项法律要求该民族范围内的白人定居者必须获得佐治亚州的许可证。塞缪尔·伍斯特拒绝申请此类许可证，认为他已经获得了切罗基人的许可在他们的土地上生活，这应该就足够了。
Georgia arrested Worcester and imprisoned him for four years. Worcester appealed to the Supreme Court, and the case, Worcester v. Georgia, became a great victory for the tribe. The Court, under Chief Justice John Marshall, ruled that the Cherokee Nation was just that, a sovereign nation within the borders of the US and, therefore, beholden only to the Federal government, i.e., not under the jurisdiction of Georgia state laws.
佐治亚州逮捕了伍斯特并将他监禁了四年。伍斯特向最高法院提出上诉，这一案件“伍斯特诉佐治亚州案”成为了部落的伟大胜利。在首席大法官约翰·马歇尔的领导下，法院裁定切罗基民族就是“民族”，是美国境内的一个主权国家，因此仅对联邦政府负责，即不受佐治亚州法律的管辖。
And the Cherokee nation was elated, you know. They thought, all right, the highest court in the land of the United States, this government that we're trying to copy, they've ruled in our favor. This is going to be good. But, of course, Andrew Jackson, who was pro-removal-- from the early years, he had campaigned on that issue-- decided he wasn't going to back the Supreme Court ruling.
切罗基民族欢欣鼓舞，你知道的。他们想，好吧，这个我们试图效仿的美国政府的最高法院已经做出了有利于我们的裁决。这下好了。但是，安德鲁·杰克逊——他从早年起就是支持驱逐政策的，并以此为议题竞选——决定不支持最高法院的裁决。
On hearing of the ruling, the President is said to have replied, "John Marshall has made his ruling, now let him enforce it." Think about that, what that means, a breakdown of the balance of power in such boasting, dictatorial terms. Jackson is violating his own oath of office to uphold the Constitution. In the 20th century, when people bandy about the idea of impeachment for presidents who fib about extramarital dalliances, it's worth remembering what a truly impeachable offense looks like. It didn't happen, of course. I refer you to the face on the $20 bill. Anyway, the state of Georgia was thrilled when Jackson thumbed his nose at the Court, and immediately dispatched teams to survey the Cherokee lands for a land lottery. Soon, white settlers arrived here.
据说总统在听到裁决时回答说：“约翰·马歇尔做出了他的裁决，现在让他去执行吧。”想想看，这意味着什么：在如此狂妄、独裁的措辞中，权力的平衡发生了崩溃。杰克逊违反了他维护宪法的就职誓言。在20世纪，当人们随意谈论弹劾那些在婚外情上撒谎的总统时，记住一个真正可弹劾的罪行是什么样子是很有价值的。当然，这并没有发生。我提醒你们看看20美元钞票上那张脸。总之，当杰克逊对法院表示蔑视时，佐治亚州兴奋不已，并立即派遣队伍去勘测切罗基土地以进行土地抽签。很快，白人定居者来到了这里。
They show up two years later in 1834-- you know, with a land lottery deed and with the Georgia soldiers saying, "I've got this land from the lottery. Get off of it."
他们两年后，也就是1834年出现了——带着土地抽签契约和佐治亚州的士兵说：“我从抽签中得到了这块地。给我滚开。”
One small constitutional violation that was part of the land grab, Georgia seized the Cherokee printing press so they couldn't publicize their cause and win political support in states up north. The tribe was divided about what to do-- stay and fight, or demand cash for the land and head west.
作为强占土地的一部分，宪法被小小的破坏了一下：佐治亚州没收了切罗基人的印刷机，这样他们就无法宣传自己的事业并在北部各州赢得政治支持。部落内部对该怎么做存在分歧——是留下来战斗，还是要求现金赔偿土地然后向西走。
No one exploited this split more than Andrew Jackson, and no one annoyed Jackson like principal chief, John Ross. Ross was a Jeffersonian figure in almost every sense, a founding father of the Cherokee nation in its modern legal form. It was Ross who cribbed from Jefferson in writing the Cherokee Constitution. Like Jefferson, he preached liberty while owning slaves. An educated, gentleman planter, Ross was only 1/8 Cherokee, just 1/8, even I'm more Cherokee than that. But he was their Chief from 1827 to 1866.
没有人比安德鲁·杰克逊更利用这种分裂，也没有人比首席酋长约翰·罗斯更让杰克逊恼火。罗斯在各个方面都是杰斐逊式的人物，是现代法律形式下切罗基民族的开国元勋。正是罗斯在撰写《切罗基宪法》时抄袭了杰斐逊。像杰斐逊一样，他在拥有奴隶的同时宣扬自由。作为一名受过教育的绅士种植园主，罗斯只有八分之一的切罗基血统，仅仅八分之一，连我的切罗基血统都比他多。但他从1827年到1866年一直担任他们的酋长。
In his later years, he corresponded with Abraham Lincoln. In his early years, he was such a believer in the inherent justice of the American system that he lobbied relentlessly in Washington DC, believing that once the Congress and the President understood that the Cherokee were a virtuous, sibling republic, that they'd treat the tribe fairly, as equals. Once the state of Georgia began evicting the Cherokee and John Ross among them, Ross wrote, "Treated like dogs, we find ourselves fugitives, vagrants, and strangers in our own country."
在他晚年，他与亚伯拉罕·林肯有书信往来。在他早年，他如此坚信美国体系内在的正义，以至于他在华盛顿特区进行不懈的游说，相信一旦国会和总统理解切罗基人是一个善良的、姐妹般的共和国，他们就会公平地对待这个部落，将其视为平等。一旦佐治亚州开始驱逐切罗基人，包括约翰·罗斯在内，罗斯写道：“我们像狗一样被对待，发现自己成了自己国家里的逃亡者、流浪者和陌生人。”
The vast majority of the tribe wanted to stay put and supported Ross. But around 100 men-- including Phoenix editor Elias Boudinot and his brother Stand Watie, 100 in a tribe of 16,000-- met at Boudinot's house in New Echota and signed a treaty with the US government. They had no authority to do this. Called the Treaty of New Echota, it relinquished all Cherokee lands east of the Mississippi in exchange for land in the West. They figured, Georgia was already seizing Cherokee land, this might be the only way the Cherokee could get something for it.
部落绝大多数人想留下来并支持罗斯。但大约100人——包括《凤凰报》编辑伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特和他的兄弟斯坦·瓦蒂，在16000人的部落中仅占100人——在新埃克塔的布迪诺特家中会面，并与美国政府签署了一项条约。他们无权这样做。这个所谓的《新埃克塔条约》放弃了所有密西西比河以东的切罗基土地，以换取西部的土地。他们心想，既然佐治亚州已经在强占切罗基土地，这可能是切罗基人能为土地换取补偿的唯一途径。
John Ross, whom the Georgia militia arrested so that he could not protest, was stunned. He accused the treaty party of treason. The rest of the 16,000 Cherokee signed a petition calling the treaty invalid and illegal. Congress ratified the treaty by only one vote, despite impassioned pleas on behalf of the Cherokee by Senators Henry Clay and Davy Crockett. The tribe was given three years to remove themselves to the West.
约翰·罗斯在被佐治亚州民兵逮捕以至于无法抗议时感到震惊。他指责条约派叛国。剩下的16000名切罗基人签署了一份请愿书，称该条约无效且非法。尽管亨利·克莱参议员和戴维·克罗克特参议员代表切罗基人进行了充满激情的呼吁，但国会还是仅以一票之差批准了该条约。部落被给了三年时间搬迁到西部。
Now we're standing at the site of Elias Boudinot's house, where the infamous New Echota treaty was signed.
现在我们正站在签署臭名昭著的《新埃克塔条约》的伊莱亚斯·布迪诺特家遗址上。
Yeah, well, the spring of '38 rolled around about like right now, and nobody was going anywhere. So Georgia and the Federal government thought they were going to have some problems. And you had about 7,000 troops come in to forcibly remove the Cherokees from their farms, from their houses. And initially rounded up into what were known as forts or stockades, and then moved up into eastern Tennessee and northeastern Alabama to three immigration depots, where they were then transferred and then moved out on the Trail of Tears as everybody knows it. So, technically, this is the starting point for the Trail of Tears. For the individual Cherokees, it really started at their front door or wherever they were rounded up from, though.
是的，1838年的春天大概就像现在这样到来，没人打算去哪儿。所以佐治亚州和联邦政府认为他们会遇到一些麻烦。大约7000名士兵进入这里，将切罗基人从他们的农场、家中强行驱逐。最初他们被关进所谓的堡垒或栅栏里，然后被转移到田纳西州东部和阿拉巴马州东北部的三个移民站，在那里他们被转移，然后走上了众所周知的眼泪之路。所以，从技术上讲，这是眼泪之路的起点。不过对于每一个切罗基人来说，它确实是从他们的前门或者任何他们被抓走的地方开始的。
Amy and I want to step on it, this patch of grass where the treaty was signed, but we hesitate. "It's not a grave," Gomez tells us. But that's what it feels like. We tiptoe onto it, this profane ground. And then we tiptoe away. Perhaps we should be embarrassed by certain discrepancies between our Trail of Tears and theirs. We're weak. We're decadent. We're Americans, which means road trip history buffs one minute, amnesiacs the next. We want to remember, except when we want to forget.
艾米和我想踏上这片签署条约的草地，但我们犹豫了。“这不是坟墓，”戈麦斯告诉我们。但感觉就像坟墓。我们踮着脚尖走上去，踏上这片亵渎的土地。然后又踮着脚尖离开。也许我们应该对我们的“眼泪之路”和他们的“眼泪之路”之间的某些差异感到羞愧。我们很软弱，我们很颓废，我们是美国人，这意味着我们上一秒是历史自驾游爱好者，下一秒就是健忘症患者。我们想要记住，除了我们想要忘记的时候。
We register at the Chattanooga Choo Choo, the Chattanooga Choo Choo. It's a hotel now. A gloriously hokey, beautifully restored Holiday Inn in which the lobby is the ornate dome of the old train station, and the rooms are turn-of-the-century rail cars parked out on the tracks.
我们在查塔努加的“呜呜火车”酒店登记入住。它现在是一家酒店了。一家极其俗气但翻修得很漂亮的假日酒店，酒店大堂是旧火车站装饰华丽的圆顶，房间则是停在铁轨上的世纪之交的火车车厢。
We're in giggles the entire night for the simple reason that the phrase "choo, choo" is completely addictive. We try to work it into every sentence. "What should we do for dinner? Stay here at the Choo Choo?" We end up going out for barbecue, saying, "This is good, but I can't wait to get back to the Choo Choo." We watch The X-Files in our train car, commenting, "Is is just me, or is this show even better in the Choo Choo?" I send email from my laptop just so that I can write, "Greetings, from the Chattanooga Choo Choo," exclamation point. Number of times I just said "choo, choo," seven. Number of choos, 14.
我们整晚都在咯咯笑，原因很简单，因为“呜呜”（choo choo）这个词简直让人上瘾。我们试图把它加进每一句话里。“我们晚饭吃什么？就在这儿吃吗？还是去呜呜？”我们最终出去吃了烧烤，说：“这很好，但我等不及要回呜呜了。”我们在车厢里看《X档案》，评论道：“只有我一个人觉得这个节目在呜呜里看起来更好看吗？”我从笔记本电脑上发送电子邮件，就为了能写上：“来自查塔努加呜呜的问候”，后面加上感叹号。我刚才说“呜呜”的次数：七次。呜呜声的总数：14声。
Day two, sadly, we check out of the Choo Choo and drive across town to Ross's Landing. It used to be where John Ross's ferry service carried people across the Tennessee River. But, in 1838, it was one of the starting points for the water route of the Trail of Tears. I stand on the sand and read a weathered historical marker.
第二天，令人遗憾的是，我们退出了呜呜，开车穿过城镇来到罗斯码头。这里曾经是约翰·罗斯的渡轮服务运送人们过田纳西河的地方。但在1838年，它是眼泪之路水路起点之一。我站在沙滩上读着一块风化的历史标记。
"Established about 1816 by John Ross, some 370 yards east of this point. It consisted of a ferry, warehouse and landing. Cherokee parties left from the landing for the West in 1838, the same year the growing community took the name Chattanooga." And I'm sure there's no connection at all between those two points. That sounds so nice. They just left for the West. Bye-bye. Bon voyage.
“由约翰·罗斯于1816年左右建立，位于此点以东约370码处。它包括一个渡轮、仓库和码头。1838年，切罗基人从这个码头出发前往西部，同年这个不断发展的社区取名查塔努加。”我相信这两个时间点之间完全没有联系。这听起来太美好了。他们只是“出发前往西部”。再见，祝旅途愉快。
I haven't mentioned that Ross's Landing also functions as Chattanooga's tourist center. Up the hill from the river is the gigantic Tennessee Aquarium and an IMAX theater. The place is crawling with tourists. A crowd so generic and indistinguishable from one another, they swirled around us as a single T-shirt.
我还没提罗斯码头也兼作查塔努加的旅游中心。在河边的山坡上是巨大的田纳西水族馆和IMAX影院。这个地方到处都是游客。一群如此普通且彼此难以区分的人群，像一件单品一样在我们周围转悠。
160 years ago, thousands of Cherokees came through this site. In the summer, they were forced onto boats and faced heat exhaustion in a drought that stranded them without water to drink. In the fall, they headed west by foot, eventually trudging barefoot through blizzards. Either way, they died of starvation, dysentery, diarrhea and fatigue. A quarter of the tribe was gone.
160年前，成千上万的切罗基人经过这个地点。夏天，他们被迫挤上船，在干旱中面临热衰竭，没有水喝。秋天，他们步行向西，最终赤脚走过暴风雪。无论哪种方式，他们都死于饥饿、痢疾、腹泻和疲劳。四分之一的部落消失了。
And here, in the shadow of the aquarium, the Trail of Tears is remembered by a series of quotations from disgruntled Native Americans carved into a concrete plaza. One of the citations, from a Cherokee named Dragging Canoe, is from 1776.
在这里，在水族馆的阴影下，眼泪之路被一系列刻在混凝土广场上的、来自不满的原住民的引语所铭记。其中一个引语来自1776年，是一个名叫“拖木筏”的切罗基人说的。
"The white men have almost surrounded us, leaving us only a little spot of ground to stand upon. And it seems to be their intention to destroy us as a nation." Good call.
“白人几乎包围了我们，只留给我们一点立足之地。他们似乎打算消灭我们这个民族。”说得好。
We're moving diagonally across the sidewalk. And Andrew Jackson, in 1820, "It is high time to do away with the farce of treatying with Indian tribes as separate nations." We'll step on that one.
我们正斜着穿过人行道。安德鲁·杰克逊在1820年曾说：“现在是时候彻底废除那种与印第安部落作为独立国家进行条约的闹剧了。”我们要踩在这一句上。
These cracks in the sidewalks, they are symbolic of broken promises.
这些人行道上的裂缝象征着被打破的承诺。
[LAUGHS] Are you making that up?
(笑) 你是编出来的吗？
No, it says right here, "Some of the pavers are cracked to symbolize the broken promises made to the Indians."
不，这里写着：“有些铺路石有裂缝，以象征对印第安人所做的破碎承诺。”
Hm.
嗯。
Most Americans have had this experience. Most of us can name things our country has done that we find shameful. From the travesties everybody agrees were wrong, the Japanese internment camps or the late date of slavery's abolition, to murkier partisan arguments about legalized abortion or the Enola Gay. World history has been a bloody business from the get-go, but the nausea we're suffering standing on the broken promises at Ross's Landing is peculiar to a democracy because, in a democracy, we're all responsible for everything our government does.
大多数美国人都经历过这种情况。我们大多数人都能说出我们国家做过的我们觉得可耻的事情。从每个人都同意是错误的暴行——比如日本人的拘留营或奴隶制废除得太晚——到关于合法堕胎或“埃诺拉·盖”号轰炸机的更模糊的党派争论。世界历史从一开始就是血腥的，但我们在罗斯码头的破碎承诺上感到的恶心对民主国家来说是特殊的，因为在民主国家，我们所有人都要为政府所做的一切负责。
This is the letter from Ralph Waldo Emerson to President Martin Van Buren in 1838. "A crime is projected that confounds our understandings by its magnitude, a crime that really deprives us as well as the Cherokee of a country. For how could we call the conspiracy that should crush these poor Indians our government, or the land that was cursed by their parting and dying imprecations, our country any more? You, sir, will bring down the renowned chair in which you sit into infamy if your seal is set to this instrument of perfidy, and the name of this nation, hitherto, the sweet omen of religion and liberty, will stink to the world."
这是拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生1838年写给马丁·范布伦总统的信。“一个因其规模而令人困惑的犯罪正在被策划，一个不仅剥夺了切罗基人，也剥夺了我们自己的国家的罪行。因为我们怎么能把那个摧毁这些可怜印第安人的阴谋称为我们的政府，或者把那片被他们离别和死亡的诅咒所诅咒的土地称为我们的国家呢？如果您将您的印章盖在这个背信弃义的工具上，您将把您所坐的著名椅子带入耻辱，而这个民族的名字，迄今为止一直是宗教和自由的甜蜜预兆，将向世界散发恶臭。”
And the path ends with a quotation from an unknown survivor of the Trail of Tears who said, "Long time we travel on way to new land. People feel bad when they leave old nation. Womens cry and make sad wails. Children, and many men, and all look sad like when friends die. But they say nothing, and just put heads down and keep on go towards west. Many days pass, and people die very much. We bury close by trail."
小径的尽头是一句来自眼泪之路幸存者的引语，他说：“我们在前往新土地的路上走了很长时间。人们离开旧民族时感觉很糟糕。女人们哭泣并发出悲伤的哀鸣。孩子们，还有许多男人，看起来都像朋友死去时那样悲伤。但他们什么也没说，只是低下头，继续朝着西边走。许多天过去了，人们死了很多。我们就在小路旁掩埋尸体。”
That last passage, especially the part about when friends die, bring us to tears. And we just stand there, looking off towards the Tennessee, brokenhearted. Meanwhile, there are little kids literally walking over these words, playing on them, making noise, having fun. We sort of hate them for a second.
最后那段话，特别是关于朋友死去的部分，让我们流下了眼泪。我们只是站在那里，看向田纳西河方向，心碎不已。与此同时，有小孩子真的在这些文字上走来走去，在上面玩耍、制造噪音、玩得很开心。我们有一秒钟简直恨死他们了。
We ask a teacher who's with a group of fourth graders why she isn't talking to them about Cherokee history. And she says normally she would, but it's the end of the school year, and this trip is their reward for being good. It sounds reasonable. I ask Amy if she thinks these kids should share our sadness.
我们问一位陪着一群四年级学生的老师，为什么她不给他们讲讲切罗基历史。她说通常她会讲，但现在是学年末，这次旅行是奖励他们的表现。这听起来很合理。我问艾米她是否认为这些孩子应该分享我们的悲伤。
Well, I think it's a sad story. It's like, I mean, it's sort of like the holocaust. You don't have to be Jewish to think that that's definitely a sad part of history. And I think the Trail of Tears is America's version of genocide. And, I mean, really, it started right over there. You look like you're about to hit something.
嗯，我认为这是一个悲伤的故事。我的意思是，这有点像大屠杀。你不必是犹太人也会认为那是历史上一个绝对悲伤的部分。而且我认为眼泪之路是美国的种族灭绝版本。我的意思是，真的，它就始于那边。你看起来好像要打人。
[LAUGHTER]
(笑声)
Still, I can't take my eyes off those children. I envy them. I want to join them. I'm an IMAX person. I had been to an IMAX theater just weeks before. I wanted to come on this trip to get a feel for this trail that made us, but standing here at Ross's Landing, it hits me how crazy that is. Suddenly, the only thing I get out of it is rage. Why should we keep going?
尽管如此，我还是无法移开注视那些孩子的目光。我羡慕他们。我想加入他们。我是个IMAX影迷。就在几周前我才去过IMAX电影院。我这次旅行是为了感受这条塑造了我们的路，但站在罗斯码头，我突然意识到这有多疯狂。突然间，我从中得到的唯一东西就是愤怒。我们为什么要继续走下去？
I don't know. I don't know why. I don't know why we're here.
我不知道。我不知道为什么。我不知道我们为什么在这里。
[LAUGHTER]
(笑声)
I seriously don't. Like, I know it's an interesting story and yes, we are always interested in our past, but sometimes I wonder what good comes of that. I don't think it makes me a more contented person at all. In fact, I think I feel really haunted by all of this, and I feel very weighed down by the pain. Part of me thinks this whole thing is a mistake. And maybe I feel more knowing about it, but it's not like this is a story where the more you know, the better you'll feel. It's just the opposite. The more I learn, the worse I feel and the more hatred I feel towards this country that I still love, and therefore, the more conflicted.
我是认真的。就像我知道这是一个有趣的故事，是的，我们总是对过去感兴趣，但有时我怀疑这有什么好处。我不认为这让我变成一个更满足的人。事实上，我觉得自己被这一切缠绕，我感到被痛苦压得喘不过气来。我的一部分觉得整件事都是个错误。也许我了解得更多了，但这并不是一个你知道得越多就感觉越好的故事。正好相反。我了解得越多，感觉就越糟糕，对我仍然热爱的这个国家感觉到的仇恨就越多，因此也就越矛盾。
I just feel all this anger at everything. And we're standing next to this stupid aquarium building and talking to coast guard guys. And there are ducks around. And now there's a calliope? I mean, I don't know. Now I just feel like-- I feel worse. I feel worse.
我只是对一切都感到愤怒。我们站在这个愚蠢的水族馆建筑旁边，和海岸警卫队的人说话。周围有鸭子。现在还有汽笛声？我的意思是，我不知道。现在我只是觉得——我感觉更糟了。我感觉更糟了。
There are only so many hours a human being can stomach unfocused dread. I was tired and confused and depressed, and I needed the kind of respite that can only come from focused resentment. In the Trail of Tears saga, if there's one person you're allowed to hate, it's Andrew Jackson, the architect of the Indian removal policy. And since the Trail of Tears passed through Nashville anyway, we stop at his plantation, The Hermitage.
人类能承受无法聚焦的恐惧的时间是有限的。我感到疲惫、困惑且沮丧，我需要那种只有通过聚焦的愤怒才能带来的喘息。在眼泪之路的传奇中，如果有一个人你可以恨，那就是安德鲁·杰克逊，印第安迁徙政策的策划者。既然眼泪之路无论如何都要经过纳什维尔，我们停在了他的种植园，冬宫。
Sarah Vowell and her sister entered the enemy's bedroom. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
莎拉·沃威尔和她的妹妹走进了敌人的卧室。那将在国际公共广播电台的节目继续后播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today, so close to the Fourth of July, a program about the past and what to make of the past. We continue with the story of Sarah Vowell and her sister, Amy, retracing the path of the Trail of Tears. They have just arrived at the home of the president responsible for the trail, someone they hate and intend to keep hating in a very un-public radio way, Andrew Jackson.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天，在接近7月4日的时候，节目是关于过去以及如何看待过去。我们继续讲述莎拉·沃威尔和她妹妹艾米重走眼泪之路的故事。她们刚刚到达负责这一迁徙道路的总统的家，那是一个她们憎恨并打算以一种非常不符合公共广播电台风格的方式继续憎恨的人：安德鲁·杰克逊。
The house and museum are closed to the public when we arrive because of astonishing tornado damage. Part of me wanted to destroy Andrew Jackson and everything he represented. Seeing all those hacked up trees made me feel like someone had beaten me to the punch.
我们到达时，因为惊人的龙卷风破坏，房子和博物馆对公众关闭了。我的一部分想要摧毁安德鲁·杰克逊和他所代表的一切。看到那些被砍倒的树让我觉得好像有人抢在我前面动手了。
God, look at it. All the trees are down.
天哪，看看它。所有的树都倒了。
Yeah.
是的。
The wrath of God.
上帝的愤怒。
Inside, there's no display mentioning Indian removal because, remarkably, there is no display about Jackson's presidency. Carolyn Brackett showed us around the house, a columned antebellum mansion that looks like a cross between Graceland and Tara. Unfortunately for my spite spree, I liked Carolyn Brackett. I felt bad for her. Like, she would point into the library and say Jackson subscribed to a lot of newspapers before his death, and I'd say, "Was one of them The Cherokee Phoenix?" She wasn't sure. She wanted to show off the mansion's painstaking restoration.
里面没有任何关于印第安人迁徙的展示，因为值得注意的是，那里根本没有关于杰克逊总统任期的展示。卡罗琳·布拉凯特带我们参观了这所房子，一栋柱廊式的战前豪宅，看起来像是雅园和塔拉庄园的结合体。不幸的是，对于我的泄愤狂欢来说，我喜欢卡罗琳·布拉凯特。我为她感到难过。比如，她会指着图书馆说杰克逊在去世前订阅了许多报纸，我会说：“其中一份是《切罗基凤凰报》吗？”她不确定。她想炫耀一下豪宅的精细修复。
All of the rooms that have original wallpaper, all of the paper was conserved and had to be cleaned with an eraser the size of a pencil eraser. So that was quite an undertaking. The portrait of Jackson was finished nine days before his death. I don't think he shows the wear and tear of his life in that portrait. The one over the--
所有有原始壁纸的房间，所有的纸都得到了保护，并且必须用铅笔橡皮大小的橡皮擦来清洁。所以那是一项相当大的工程。杰克逊的肖像画在他去世前九天完成。我不认为他在那幅肖像中表现出了他生活中的磨损。那幅在……之上的。
Hey. He looks like he's sticking his head out a car window.
嘿。他看起来像是把头探出车窗。
[LAUGHTER]
(笑声)
I guess he wasn't worrying about his hair much by then.
我猜他那时已经不太关心他的头发了。
Carolyn guides us past the flower garden planted by Jackson's wife, Rachel, and into the family graveyard. There are a few piddly headstones and one Greco-Roman monstrosity with an obelisk rising from the center.
卡罗琳带着我们走过杰克逊的妻子雷切尔种植的花园，进入了家庭墓地。那里有几块破烂的墓碑，中心有一座希腊罗马式的怪胎建筑，竖着一座方尖碑。
Let me guess which one of these graves is Jackson's. [LAUGHS]
让我猜猜这些坟墓里哪一个是杰克逊的。(笑)
Here he is. He actually had this designed for Rachel and left room for himself. And these are other family members.
就在这里。他实际上是为雷切尔设计的这个，并给自己留了位置。这些是其他家庭成员。
I pull a book out of my backpack, a book with the subtitle, Andrew Jackson and the Subjugation of the American Indian . Carolyn and Amy exchange a worried look.
我从背包里掏出一本书，副标题是《安德鲁·杰克逊与美洲印第安人的征服》。卡罗琳和艾米交换了一个担忧的眼神。
Well, so I'm standing here on Andrew Jackson's grave. And there is part of me, as a person of partly Cherokee descent, that wouldn't mind dancing on it. [LAUGHS] You know? I would like to-- there's a letter that Jackson wrote about the removal of the Southeastern tribes. And-- can you hold that, Amy-- this is his opinion on the Southeastern tribes leaving their land.
好吧，我现在站在安德鲁·杰克逊的坟墓上。作为一名有部分切罗基血统的人，我心里有一部分不介意在他的坟墓上跳舞。(笑) 你知道吗？我想要——杰克逊写过一封关于东南部部落迁徙的信。而且——你能拿一下那个吗，艾米——这是他对东南部部落离开他们的土地的看法。
"Doubtless, it will be painful to leave the graves of their fathers. But what do they more than our ancestors did nor than our children are doing? To better their condition in an unknown land, our forefathers left all that was dear in earthly objects. Our children by thousands yearly leave the land of their birth to seek new homes in distant regions."
“毫无疑问，离开他们祖先的坟墓会很痛苦。但他们做得比我们的祖先做的或者我们的孩子正在做的更多吗？为了改善他们在未知土地上的条件，我们的先辈抛弃了所有尘世间珍贵的东西。我们的孩子们每年成千上万地离开出生的土地，去遥远的地区寻找新的家园。”
And then it ends, "Can it be cruel in the government, when, by events which it cannot control, the Indian is made discontent in his ancient home to purchase his lands, give him a new and extensive territory, to pay the expense of his removal, and support him a year in his new abode. How many thousands of our own people would gladly embrace the opportunity of removing to the West on such conditions?"
然后结尾写道：“当由于政府无法控制的事件，使印第安人在其古老的家园感到不满时，政府购买他们的土地，给他一块新的广阔领土，支付他迁徙的费用，并资助他在新住所生活一年，这能算是残忍吗？我们自己的人民中有多少成千上万的人会乐意接受这种迁徙到西部的机会呢？”
I mean, there's something sort of nutty about Old Hickory in this passage. You know, just the fact that he just thinks-- well, to compare the removal of Indians from their land with the opportunity of his generation to just go out west. I mean, what do you make of that? Can you help me understand that mindset?
我的意思是，在这个段落里，“老胡桃木”（指杰克逊）身上有一种疯狂的东西。你知道，仅仅是他认为——好吧，将印第安人从他们的土地上迁走与他那一代人仅仅去西部开辟未来做比较。我的意思是，你怎么看这个？你能帮我理解那种心态吗？
Probably not. I mean, the interesting thing about that era was that they really felt that they were preserving. This is how they justified it in their own minds was that they were actually having preserve it, that this was inevitable. It was sort of the early thought of manifest destiny, that it was inevitable that this would happen.
恐怕不能。我的意思是，那个时代有趣的是，他们真的觉得自己是在“保护”。在他们自己的头脑中，这就是他们证明其合理性的方式：他们实际上是在保护印第安人，这是不可避免的。这有点像是“昭昭天命”的早期思想，认为这一切发生是不可避免的。
Interestingly, to me, is they never seemed to think that we were going to settle the country all the way to the West, all the way to California. So, if they just kept moving everybody further away, they would suddenly get to a point where there wasn't going to be any settlement, which, of course, didn't happen.
有趣的是，他们似乎从来没有想过我们会一直定居到西部，一直到加利福尼亚。所以，如果他们只是不停地把每个人搬得更远，他们就会突然到达一个没有定居点的地方，当然，这并没有发生。
We drive on into Kentucky towards Hopkinsville. When the Trail of Tears passed through southern Kentucky in December of 1838, a traveler from Maine happened upon a group of Cherokees. He wrote, "We found them in the forest by a roadside camped for the night under a severe fall of rain accompanied by a heavy wind. Canvas for a shield against the inclemency of the weather and the cold, wet ground for a resting place, after the fatigue of the day, they spent the night."
我们开车前往肯塔基州，驶向霍普金斯维尔。当眼泪之路在1838年12月经过肯塔基州南部时，一位来自缅因州的旅行者偶然碰见了一群切罗基人。他写道：“我们在森林里的路边发现他们，在严重的降雨和狂风中露宿一夜。帆布作为抵御天气严酷的盾牌，潮湿寒冷的地面作为一天的疲劳后的栖身之所，他们就这样度过了夜晚。”
"Several were then quite ill, and an aging man we were then informed was in the last struggles of death. Even aged females, apparently ready to drop into the grave, were traveling with heavy burdens attached to the back, on the sometimes frozen ground and the sometimes muddy streets with no covering for the feet except for what nature had given them. We learned from the inhabitants on the road where the Indians passed that they buried 14 or 15 at every stopping place."
“当时有好几个人病得很重，我们被告知一位老人正在垂死挣扎。即使是看起来快要掉进坟墓的老妇人，也在背上背着沉重的负担，走在有时冻结的地面和有时泥泞的街道上，除了大自然给她们的东西外，没有任何覆盖脚的东西。我们从路上的居民那里得知，印第安人经过的地方，他们在每一个停靠点都埋葬了14或15个人。”
John Ross's wife died in a place like this, in winter, of pneumonia. She had one blanket to protect herself from the weather, and she gave it to a sick child during a sleet storm.
约翰·罗斯的妻子就是在这样的地方，在冬天，死于肺炎。她只有一条毯子来保护自己免受天气影响，但在暴风雪中，她把毯子让给了一个生病的孩子。
There's more. It gets worse. I always knew the Cherokee owned slaves, that they owned them in the East and that they owned them in the West. Only in the course of this road trip did it occur to me that the slaves got to Indian territory in the same manner as their masters, on the Trail of Tears. Can you imagine? As if being a slave wasn't bad enough? To be a slave to a tortured Indian made to walk halfway across the continent?
还有更多。情况变得更糟了。我一直知道切罗基人拥有奴隶，他们在东部拥有奴隶，在西部也拥有奴隶。只是在这次自驾游的过程中，我才意识到奴隶们是以同样的方式到达印第安领地的：走在眼泪之路上。你能想象吗？好像身为奴隶还不够糟糕似的？还要成为一个饱受折磨的印第安人的奴隶，被迫走半个大陆？
Day three, Hopkinsville. We stopped here because it was on the map, but pulling into town we saw signs for a Trail of Tears Memorial Park we didn't know about. It seemed like a good idea to go there.
第三天，霍普金斯维尔。我们停在这里是因为地图上有标注，但开车进城时，我们看到了一个我们不知道的“眼泪之路纪念公园”的标志。去那里看起来是个好主意。
Good morning.
早上好。
Do you work here?
你在这里工作吗？
Yes, I do.
是的，我是。
Mind if we bother you a second?
介意我们打扰你一下吗？
What you need?
你需要什么？
Can you tell me about what the origin of this place is, and why there's a park here, and how it came about?
你能告诉我这个地方的由来吗，为什么这里有一个公园，它是怎么来的？
Hopkinsville was a ration stop along the way on the Trail of Tears, and the Cherokee camped here. They were here for a week or so. While they were here, two of their chiefs died, and they're buried up on the hillside. You should start here and walk up to the grave area. There are three bronze plaques on each one of the posts. The last one, just before you enter the grave area, tells you about the two chiefs, Whitepath and Flysmith.
霍普金斯维尔是眼泪之路上的一站，切罗基人曾在此露营。他们在这里待了一周左右。当他们在这里时，他们的两位酋长去世了，被埋在山坡上。你应该从这里开始，走到墓地区域。每根柱子上都有三块青铜牌匾。就在你进入墓地区域前的那一块，告诉了你关于两位酋长怀特帕斯和弗莱史密斯的事。
The plaque nearest the graves says that Whitepath was one of the Cherokee who fought under Andrew Jackson in 1814 at the Battle of Horseshoe Bend. Jackson even gave Whitepath a watch for his bravery. In that battle, a Cherokee saved Jackson's life, which hints at the level of Jackson's betrayal of the tribe. Had a Cherokee not saved his life then, Whitepath and Flysmith might not be buried here beneath our feet.
最靠近坟墓的牌匾上说，怀特帕斯是1814年在马蹄弯战役中效忠于安德鲁·杰克逊的切罗基人之一。杰克逊甚至因为怀特帕斯的勇敢而送给他一块手表。在那场战斗中，一名切罗基人救了杰克逊的性命，这暗示了杰克逊对部落背叛的程度。如果没有一个切罗基人在那时救了他的命，怀特帕斯和弗莱史密斯可能就不会被埋在我们脚下这里了。
The graves are up on a little hill. You can hear the highway down below, but still it's serene. Up until this moment, all the graves along the trail had been metaphorical. All through Tennessee Amy and I kept saying, "We're driving over graves. We're driving over graves." But, even then, we just imagined them there, under the blacktop, off in the woods. But here, the skeletons suddenly had faces, specific stories. The graves were real.
坟墓在这一小座山上。你可以听到下面高速公路的声音，但这里依然宁静。直到这一刻，沿途所有的坟墓都是隐喻性的。整个田纳西州之行，艾米和我一直在说：“我们开车经过坟墓。我们开车经过坟墓。”但即便如此，我们只是想象它们就在那里，在柏油路下，在树林里。但在这里，骸骨突然有了面孔，有了具体的故事。坟墓是真实的。
It took the Cherokee about six months to walk to Oklahoma. We're doing it in five days. Every 10 minutes, we cover the same amount of ground they covered in a day. We drive with the sun in our eyes on back roads through Kentucky. We duck into a remote section of downstate Illinois Chicagoans fear to tread. A plaque marks the spot where thousands of Cherokee camped, unable to cross the Mississippi because of floating ice. We cross it in under a minute.
切罗基人步行到俄克拉荷马州大约花了六个月。我们用五天时间完成了。每10分钟，我们行驶的路程就是他们一天走过的路。我们顶着阳光在肯塔基州的乡间小路上行驶。我们穿入伊利诺伊州南部的一个偏远地区，那是芝加哥人不敢涉足的地方。一块牌匾标志着成千上万的切罗基人曾在此露营，因为浮冰无法渡过密西西比河。我们在一分钟内就横跨了它。
I know we're going fast, but it doesn't feel fast. We plod through most of Missouri stopping at yet another Trail of Tears State Park. There's actually a name for what we're doing, it's called heritage tourism, which sounds so grand, like it's going to be one freaking epiphany after another. But, after a while, we just read the signs without even getting out of the car. At the end of every day we fall into our motel beds, wrecked.
我知道我们走得很快，但感觉并不快。我们走过了密苏里州的大部分地区，在另一个“眼泪之路州立公园”停了下来。我们所做的事情实际上有一个名字，叫“遗产旅游”，听起来很宏大，好像会一个接一个地产生重大顿悟。但过了一会儿，我们甚至不用下车就读完了那些标牌。每天结束时，我们都会瘫倒在汽车旅馆的床上，精疲力竭。
Day four, in the morning, we plow through Arkansas. We get to Fayetteville in the afternoon. We have lunch with two old roommates of mine, Brad and Leilani, who take us to a little Trail of Tears marker next to a high school parking lot.
第四天早上，我们穿过阿肯色州。下午我们到达了费耶特维尔。我们和我的两个老室友布拉德和蕾拉妮吃了午饭，他们带我们去了高中停车场旁边的一个“眼泪之路”标记处。
That looks plaque-like, huh? "On this site, in the summer of 1839, there camped 1,000 Cherokees, men women and children en route to their new home."
那看起来像块牌匾，对吧？“在此地，1839年夏天，有1000名切罗基人露营，包括在前往新家园路上的男女老少。”
The sign's facing a semicircular arrangement of boulders. Anyone who's ever been to high school would recognize it immediately as the place students go to sneak cigarettes or get stoned. And, once again, it's striking how the two American tendencies exist side by side, to remember our past and to completely ignore it and have fun.
标牌正对着半圆形的巨石阵。任何去过高中读书的人都会立刻认出这是学生们溜出去抽烟或吸毒的地方。而且，再次令人震惊的是，两种美国人的倾向并存：记住我们的过去，以及完全忽视它并享受乐趣。
Look at how we treat all our national holidays. Don't we mourn the dead on Memorial Day with volleyball and sunscreen? Don't we, the people, commemorate the Fourth of July by setting meat and bottle rockets on fire? Which makes a lot of sense when you remember that a phrase as weird and whimsical as "the pursuit of happiness" sits right there in the second sentence of the founding document of the country.
看看我们是如何对待所有国定假日的。我们难道不是在国殇日用排球和防晒霜来哀悼死者吗？我们这些人民难道不是通过点燃肉类和冲天炮来纪念7月4日吗？当你记住像“追求幸福”这样奇怪而异想天开的短语就写在国家立国文件的第二句话里时，这很有意义。
The most happiness I find on the trip is when we're in the car and I can blare the Chuck Berry tape I brought. We drive the trail where thousands died, and I listen to the music and think what are we supposed to do with the grisly past? I feel a righteous anger and bitterness about every historical fact of what the American nation did to the Cherokee. But, at the same time, I'm an entirely American creature. I'm in love with this song and the country that gave birth to it.
我在旅途中发现的最大幸福就是当我们在车里，我可以大声播放我带来的查克·贝里磁带时。我们开在成千上万人死去的路上，我听着音乐，心想我们该拿这些惨痛的过去怎么办？我对美国国家对切罗基人所做的一切历史事实感到一种正义的愤怒和痛苦。但是，与此同时，我是一个完全地道的美国生物。我热爱这首歌，也热爱那个孕育了它的国家。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "BACK IN THE USA" BY CHUCK BERRY]
(音乐播放 - 查克·贝里的《回到美国》)
Listening to "Back in the USA" while driving the Trail of Tears, I turn it over and over in my head. It's a good country. It's a bad country. Good country, bad country. And, of course, it's both. When I think about my relationship with America, I feel like a battered wife. Yeah, he knocks me around a lot, but boy he sure can dance.
在开眼泪之路时听着《回到美国》，我在脑海里反反复复地想。这是一个好国家。这是一个坏国家。好国家，坏国家。当然，两者皆是。当我想起我和美国的关系时，我觉得自己像个被虐待的妻子。是的，他经常把我打得团团转，但天哪，他确实跳得一手好舞。
"Welco to Oklahoma, Native America." Huh, I don't remember the signs used to say that. Do you?
“欢迎来到俄克拉荷马州，印第安人的故乡。”哈，我不记得标志以前是这样写的。你记得吗？
No. I think, didn't they used to say, "Oklahoma's OK?"
不。我想，它们以前不是写着“俄克拉荷马还可以”吗？
Well--
嗯——
I think that's about right too. Eh, it's OK.
我觉得那也差不多。呃，还行吧。
[LAUGHTER]
(笑声)
Across the state line, we're in the Western Cherokee Nation. And the maddening thing, the heartbreaking, cruel, sad, cold fact is that Northeastern Oklahoma looks exactly like Northwestern Georgia. Same old trees. Same old grassy farmland. The Cherokee walked all this way, crossed rivers, suffered blizzards, buried their dead, and all for what? The same old land they left.
穿过州界，我们就在西部切罗基民族了。令人抓狂的、心碎的、残酷的、悲伤的、冷冰冰的事实是，俄克拉荷马州东北部看起来和佐治亚州西北部一模一样。同样的树，同样的草地农田。切罗基人走了这么远的路，跨过河流，忍受暴风雪，埋葬死者，这一切是为了什么？还是他们离开时的那片土地。
We breeze through Tahlequah, the Cherokee capital. Even though the Trail of Tears officially stops there, our trail won't be over until we get to our hometown, Braggs. It's about 20 minutes away, and we plan on spending the evening with our aunts and uncles there.
我们轻松穿过切罗基首都塔勒阔。尽管眼泪之路正式在这里停止，但我们的路要到我们的家乡布拉格斯才算结束。它在大约20分钟车程之外，我们打算晚上和我们的姑姑叔叔们在那里度过。
[KNOCKS ]
(敲门声)
Come inside girls.
进来吧，孩子们。
Hi.
嗨。
Hi. [LAUGHS]
嗨。(笑)
Oh, hi. Oh, it's so good to see you. Hi, Amy.
哦，嗨。哦，见到你们真是太好了。嗨，艾米。
How you doing?
你怎么样？
Oh.
哦。
Hi uncle.
嗨，叔叔。
I wanted to talk to my uncle, John A, my mother's brother. At 74, he's my oldest living relative. I asked him about his great grandfather, Peter Parson, who came to Oklahoma on the Trail of Tears.
我想和我的叔叔约翰·A谈谈，我母亲的哥哥。74岁，他是我最年长的在世亲戚。我问他关于他的曾祖父彼得·帕森的事情，他是走在眼泪之路上来到俄克拉荷马州的。
He was 12 years old, and he grew up here from 12 years old. And he was a stone mason, and some of his work is still around Tahlequah. If you're going up to the village tomorrow, you'll see two big columns.
他当时12岁，从12岁起就在这里长大。他是个石匠，他的一些作品现在还在塔勒阔。如果你明天去村子里，你会看到两根大柱子。
He built those?
是他造的？
He helped build those two columns. See, they built that right after they came up here.
他帮忙造了那两根柱子。看，他们来这里之后就造了那个。
I didn't know that. The columns he's talking about, and there are actually three instead of two, are the great symbols of the Cherokee nation in the West. For years, I've had an old photograph of them stuck on my refrigerator door. They're all that's left of the remains of the Cherokee Female Seminary, the very first public school for girls west of the Mississippi, which my great-grandmother attended.
我不知道。他说的那些柱子，实际上有三根而不是两根，是西部切罗基民族的伟大象征。多年来，我的冰箱门上一直贴着一张它们的旧照片。它们是切罗基女子神学院遗迹中仅存的部分，那是密西西比河以西第一所女子公立学校，我的曾祖母曾在那里上学。
Everything about the journey until now has been a little world-historical. Hearing that our ancestor helped build the columns is the first time I felt an actual familial connection to the story. I asked John A about our family and the Cherokee presence in Oklahoma. I ask him a lot of off-topic questions about his service in World War II, mainly because I was dying to. I was never allowed to ask him about it when I was a kid.
到目前为止，旅途中的一切都有点世界历史的味道。听到我们的祖先帮忙建造这些柱子，是我第一次在这个故事中感受到真正的家族联系。我问约翰·A关于我们家庭和切罗基人在俄克拉荷马州的存在。我问了他许多关于他二战服役经历的题外话，主要是因为我太想知道了。我小时候从来不被允许问他。
And then I asked him a mundane, reporterly question about whether he thinks the state of Oklahoma has done a good job educating its students about American Indian history. He says yes, then jumps into a non sequitur about his own education that I haven't been able to stop thinking about since.
然后我问了他一个世俗的、记者的提问，问他是否认为俄克拉荷马州在教育学生了解美洲印第安人历史方面做得很好。他说很好，然后跳到一个关于他自己教育的题外话，自那以后我一直无法停止思考。
I just wish that I could've, maybe, went to school a lot more. Yeah, I didn't get no education, and that was one of my big faults. But, when I was growing up, it took everybody to make a living, so I had to work. There's Hoy, he's got a Master's Degree in Education, and I got to third grade. [LAUGHS] Did you know that?
我只是希望我能，也许，多上点学。是的，我没受过什么教育，那是我最大的缺点之一。但是，当我长大时，需要全家人努力才能维持生计，所以我必须工作。你看霍伊，他有教育学硕士学位，而我只上了三年级。(笑) 你知道吗？
No, third grade?
不知道，三年级？
That's all I went, to the third grade. Duke was about third or fourth grade. We didn't get no education. So what you learn you can't afford to forget, you know?
我就上了三年级。杜克也就三年级或四年级。我们没受过教育。所以你学到的东西你不能忘记，你知道吗？
On this trip, I've been so wrapped up in all the stories of all the deaths on the Trail of Tears, sitting there listening to my uncle ask what if, I realized that there are lots of ways that lives are pummeled by history. If the Trail of Tears is a glacier that inched its way west my uncle is one of the boulders it deposited when it stopped. He had to work the farm, and the farm he worked was what was left of his grandfather's Indian allotment.
这次旅行中，我一直沉浸在眼泪之路上所有死亡的故事中，坐在那里听着我叔叔问“如果当初会怎样”，我意识到生活中有很多方式会被历史重创。如果眼泪之路是一条缓慢向西移动的冰川，那么我叔叔就是它停止时留下的巨石之一。他必须经营农场，而他经营的农场是他祖父留下的印第安分配土地。
And then came the Dust Bowl, and then came the war. All these historical forces bore down on him, but he did not break. Compared to him, compared to the people we descend from, I am free of history. I'm so free of history I have to get in a car and drive seven states to find it.
然后是黑风暴事件，然后是战争。所有这些历史力量都压在他身上，但他没有崩溃。与他相比，与我们祖先相比，我没有历史的束缚。我太没有历史的束缚了，以至于我必须开车跨越七个州才能找到它。
It's good to know where you're from, to know where your beginning is. It really, probably, don't amount to all that much, only just to one's self, you know? It has nothing to do with you getting out here doing what you're going to do tomorrow or a week or two from now. But, at least, if you want to look back, you can look back, maybe on this trip, and say well, I was down in the area there where some of my ancestors originated from, you know?
知道自己从哪里来，知道自己的起点在哪里是件好事。它可能并没有多大的意义，只是为了自己而已，你知道吗？它和你明天或一两周后要出去做的事情无关。但是，至少如果你想回顾过去，你可以回顾一下，也许在这次旅行中，你可以说，嗯，我当时就在我的一些祖先发源的地方，你知道吗？
Day five, Tsa-La-Gi.
第五天，Tsa-La-Gi。
Do you remember this, Amy?
你还记得这个吗，艾米？
What?
什么？
Do you remember this?
你还记得这个吗？
Yeah, don't you?
记得啊，你不记得吗？
Yeah.
记得。
I mean, we came here once a year.
我的意思是，我们每年都来这里。
Those columns are a lot smaller than I remembered. I remember them just being these arrows into the sky, and they can't be more than, what? 20 feet tall?
那些柱子比我记忆中要小得多。我记得它们就像是射向天空的箭，而它们现在肯定不超过20英尺高，是吗？
Oh, I think they're taller than that.
哦，我觉得它们更高一点。
Oh, look. Now we're at-- this is the amphitheater entrance. [SIGHS] Oh, here's where you'd get your program. Walk up here, and there's the statue of Sequoyah.
哦，看。我们现在在——这是露天剧场的入口。(叹气) 哦，这是你买节目单的地方。走上这里，那边是塞阔雅的雕像。
Over there's where the Phoenix would rise again.
那边是凤凰重生的地方。
Over there, isn't that-- oh, down there, on the right, that's where I remember Stand Watie was always throwing a fit. [LAUGHS]
那边，那不是——哦，在右边下面，我记得斯坦·瓦蒂总是会在那里发脾气。(笑)
I always thought he was over there.
我一直以为他在那边。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
Unfortunately, due to loss of funding, the drama here at Tsa-La-Gi won't be performed this summer. Amy and I sit in the chairs where we first learned about the Trail of Tears and talk about our trip. Our experiences were different. She minored in Native American studies in college. She not only owns a copy of Black Elk Speaks , she could quote from it. And, for her, the trip was about empathy.
不幸的是，由于资金短缺，今年夏天Tsa-La-Gi不会上演这部剧。艾米和我坐在我们第一次了解眼泪之路的椅子上，谈论我们的旅行。我们的经历不同。她在大学辅修了美洲原住民研究。她不仅拥有一本《黑麋鹿如是说》，她还能引用其中的话。对她来说，这次旅行是关于同理心。
You know, I've been pretty close to tears sometimes just thinking about the pain, or whatever, like what the kids must have been thinking. When we were driving, I just kept imagining the kids saying, "Where are we going? Where are we going?" You know, like, "What is happening?" I guess I've been thinking about what it really must have been like.
你知道，有时我真的快要哭了，只要想到那种痛苦，或者别的什么，就像孩子们一定在想什么。当我们开车时，我一直在想象孩子们在说：“我们要去哪儿？我们要去哪儿？”你知道，就像“发生了什么？”我想我一直在想当时的情况到底是什么样的。
I've been thinking about those kids too. But the person I identify with most in this history is John Ross, the principal chief during the Trail of Tears, because he was caught between the two nations. He believed in the possibilities of the American constitution enough to make sure the Cherokee had one too. He believed in the liberties, the Declaration of Independence's promises, and the civil rights the constitution ensures.
我也一直在想那些孩子。但我在这段历史中最能产生共鸣的人是约翰·罗斯，眼泪之路期间的首席酋长，因为他被夹在两个民族之间。他相信美国宪法的可能性，以至于确保切罗基人也有了一部。他相信自由，相信《独立宣言》的承诺，相信宪法所确保的公民权利。
And, when the US betrayed not only the Cherokee but its own creed, I would guess that John Ross was not only angry, not only outraged, not only confused, I would guess that John Ross was a little brokenhearted because that's how I feel. I've been experiencing the Trail of Tears not as a Cherokee, but as an American.
当美国不仅背叛了切罗基人，也背叛了自己的信仰时，我猜约翰·罗斯不仅愤怒，不仅气愤，不仅困惑，我猜约翰·罗斯有点心碎了，因为我也是这种感觉。我并不是作为一个切罗基人，而是作为一个美国人感受到了眼泪之路。
John Ridge, one of the signers of the treaty of New Echota, once prophesied, "Cherokee blood, if not destroyed, will wind its courses in beings of fair complexions, who will read that their ancestors became civilized under the frowns of misfortunes and the causes of their enemies." He was talking about people like my sister and me. The story of the Trail of Tears, like the story of America, is as complicated as our Cherokee-Swedish-Scottish-English-French-Seminole family tree. Just as our blood will never be pure, the Trail of Tears will never make sense.
《新埃克塔条约》的签署人之一约翰·里奇曾预言：“切罗基人的血液，如果没被消灭，将在肤色白皙的人身上蜿蜒流淌，他们会读到他们的祖先是在不幸的皱眉和敌人的原因下变得文明的。”他说的就是像我妹妹和我这样的人。眼泪之路的故事，就像美国的故事一样，像我们的切罗基-瑞典-苏格兰-英国-法国-塞米诺尔家族树一样复杂。就像我们的血统永远不会纯正一样，眼泪之路也永远不会有明确的解释。
Sarah Vowell, she's put a version of her story about the Trail of Tears into her book, Take the Cannoli: Stories from the New World.
莎拉·沃威尔把她关于眼泪之路的故事版本写进了她的书《带上卡诺里：新世界的故事》中。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Nancy Updike and Alix Spiegel. Senior editor for this show, Paul Tough. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere, Sarah Vowell. Production help from Pat Hannah, Laura Doggit and Sylvia Lemus.
好吧，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，南希·厄普代克和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔协助。本节目高级编辑：保罗·塔夫。特约编辑：杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林，顾问：莎拉·沃威尔。制作协助：帕特·汉娜、劳拉·多吉特和西尔维娅·莱姆斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
(鸣谢)
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for free or buy tapes. Or, you know, you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even The New York Times all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们的节目或购买磁带。或者，你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
(资金鸣谢)
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatea, who today is hearing our program from Chattanooga and asks.
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他今天正在查塔努加收听我们的节目并询问。
Is it just me, or is this show even better in the Choo Choo?
只有我一个人觉得这个节目在呜呜里看起来更好看吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。